[Music]
game of thrones prequel series house of
the dragon although based on george rr
martin's targaryen history book fire and
blood will not feature only targaryens
but many other houses and many other
legendary figures from that time period
as well
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on georgia martin's book fire
and blood vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood volume 1. the aton
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1
ended with rhinera targaryen's son aegon
iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war with dorne and go all
the way to the mad king
and robert's rebellion that attended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the show is also the
key in the history of house targaryen
the dance of the dragons
the targaryen civil war which divided
the entire kingdom
and launched a huge war that was fought
from 129 ac to 131ac
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half-sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens
brothers fought brothers dragons fought
the dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead craig and stark known as the old
man of the north the wolf of the north
and the wolf of wennerfeld was the lord
of winterfell
and the head of house stark during the
targaryen civil war
a huge north man with a hard face
dressed in fur
and iron lord kragen was a pillar of
strength and his presence by itself
would command fear and respect
he briefly ruled king's landing in the
hour of the wolf
when he brought order and justice to the
capital and served as hand of the king
for aegon iii
after the dance of the dragons craig and
stark was born in 108 ac
the eldest son of lord rickon stark and
lady gillian glower
kragen became the lord of minerfel and
the warden of the north in 121 ac at the
age of 13
when his lord father passed away during
his minority his uncle bannard ruled the
north as a regent
when creagan turned 16 and came of age
in 124 ac
bannard was slow to surrender his power
relations between kragen and baynard
grew strained
as the young lord of winner felt shaved
under the limits imposed on him by his
uncle
before fighting someone else's war
kragen had to fight his own war to get
what was rightfully his
to take the rule of the north from his
uncle upon himself
three years before the dance of the
dragon started in 126 ac
kragen finally rose up against his uncle
and imprisoned banner than his three
sons
taking the rule of the north into his
own hands upon the death of king viserys
the first targaryen
rhaenyra's son prince jacary's valerian
flew to winterfell on his dragon vermax
to gain the support of the starks and
the north for his mother rhaenyra
targaryen's claim to the iron throne
the alliance known as the pact of ice
and fire stated that a targaryen
princess the future first-born daughter
of jacarys would marry his son rickon
kragen pledged his support to the blacks
during the dance of the dragons
kragen had a bastard half-sister and
mushroom's rivaled account of the war
claims that jacarys fell in love with
and sacredly married the girl at
winterfell's godswood
after prince jacary's valerian secured
the allegiance of the north for his
mother rhaenyra targaryen
lord craig and stark sent two thousand
soldiers known as the winter wolf south
commanded by his bannermen lord rodrick
dustin known as roddy de roy to support
the queen's claim
while he remained in the north to gather
his own banners
due to the vastness of the north this
would take long
the winter wolves were grizzled soldiers
who rode shaggy northern horses
for old male and ragged skins will the
dexes smalls
spiked maces and ancient iron swords it
was long the custom in the north for
older men to leave their homes in winter
and thereby preserve supplies for their
younger kin
so the winter wolves expected they would
die while marching for glory adventure
and plunder
we have come to die for the dragon queen
said lord roderick while leading 2
thousand winter wolves into battle
there's probably nothing scarier than
fighting men who have come to die
during the battle by the lakeshore the
winter wolves led the attack
and charged the lannister spearmen five
times with two-thirds of the northmen
killed or wounded in their decisive
victory for the blacks
during the butcher's bowl lord rodriguez
sounded the charge of the winter wolves
and the river knight allies against sir
kristen cole's army in the ensuing
butcher's bowl
a slaughter of the greens during the
first battle of tamilton
the surviving winter wolves screamed
northern war cries
and rode from a postern gate despite
being outnumbered by
10 to 1 lord roderick led the northmen
in a charge against lord ormund
hightower
as the singers tell it lord rodrick was
blood from head to heel as he came on
yet so drunk with the battle that he did
not even seem to feel his wounds
lord dorman's nephew sir bryden was able
to cut off roderick's shield arm with a
long axe
but the northern lord was able to kill
both hightowers before succumbing to his
wounds
rhaenyra fled king's landing after the
storming of the dragonpit
while she was staying at duskendale lord
stark wrote that he would gather for her
a host of 10 000 northmen younger and
fiercer than the fallen winter wolves
rhaenyra was killed at dragonstone by
king aegon the second targaryen
however but kragen with his army still
marched south nonetheless in support of
her son
prince aegon the younger the war
continued between the supporters of the
dead queen and the king's remaining
loyalists
riverlands the north and the vale still
supported the claim of rhaenyra's sun
egg on the third
while aegon ii only had the stormlands
army able to defend him
the lord stark moved south with his army
to overthrow aegon the second
and placed rhaenyra's son on the armed
throne lord boris baratheon was marching
north with his
own banners but he was defeated on the
king's road by the riverlords known as
the lads
before lord stark arrived having failed
to get the battle he wanted stark
nevertheless wanted to punish those who
had supported aegon ii
he moved his forces to claim king's
landing where he found that hagon ii had
been poisoned
and dagon iii was now a king since he
was aged 11
a regency needed to be established and
several lords were vying
for power with his formidable presence
and character as well as with his army
lord stark was the most powerful man in
king's landing
with his new found power lord stark
wanted to punish those who had supported
aegon ii
such as the baratheons the lannisters
and the high towers
however lord corliss valerian had
already sent envoys to old town
stormzand and casterly rock to make
peace
while the word of the end voice was
being waited upon there was another
matter that lord stark wanted to deal
with
the assassination of aegon ii while he
had believed that he had been a usurper
and had been riding
south to oust him from power lord stark
did not believe in killing him
but rather in defeating him on the field
of battle he declared
that all those who had partaken in the
killing needed to be punished
his troops arrested several people in
the capital
including lord valerian lord larry
strong the master of whispers
and several members of the kingsguard
after these arrests were made lord stark
was appointed hand of the king by king
aegon iii
during the day that followed his
appointment lord stark led
the trials and execution of the traitors
sending mouse to the wall and executing
a member of the kingsguard
and lord strong who refused to take the
black following the traditions of house
stark lord creagan beheaded them both
himself with
ice the valyrian still great sword of
the starks
this event came to be known as the hour
of the wolf or the judgment of the wolf
lord valerian escaped execution or
sentence when the king
issued an edict that he was to be spared
and returned to his former dignity as
lord of the tides
creighton married alice in blackwood in
exchange for honoring aegon the third's
pardon of lord corliss
lord stark resigned as the hand the
following day and left king's landing
for winterfell
the snobs are falling in the north and
my place is at winterfell
said craigan explaining why he cannot
stay at king's landing
it was during regan's long reign as lord
of winner felt that house stark's
loyalty to the iron throne
doubtful at best prior to this became a
certainty king aegon iii
targaryen granted many rewards to kragen
although a targaryen princess
never married into house stark some time
after the war cragon fought with taemon
targaryen the dragonite
the prince of house targaryen the member
of the kingsguard and one of the
greatest swordsmen of his age
and ever in the history of westeros and
was only barely defeated
amon claimed he had never faced a finer
swordsman than lord kragen
his name is mentioned within the entry
of aemon targaryen in the book of
brothers
kragen went on to have a long life which
earned him the nickname of the old man
of the north
kragen was entombed in the crypts of nfl
craig stark will definitely be one of my
favorite characters in the house of the
dragon
an honorable man who upholds his oath to
queen rhaenyra
and whose men the winter wolves fought
during most of the war
and during the blacks quite a few
important victories in the riverlands
legendary characters such as craig stark
legendary battles such as the winter
wolves
charge into the green's army despite
being outnumbered by 10 to one
and managing to reach the commander of
the greens and seeing a stark rule the
capital king's landing
of that and more this game of thrones
prequel show house of the dragon brings
in 2022
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comments section down below
thank you so much for watching and i
hope to see you in the next one peace